although the unholy is based on a work
of fiction you don't necessarily need to
read the 1983 novel to get the most out
of the movie but there are aspects of
the story that make reference to real
events that some have interpreted as
true life miracles
a few of these instances are called out
by bishop james giles in a press
conference as an attempt to explain
their significance to the media he
quickly summarizes how each of them
resulted in the nomination of a holy
shrine but all of these stories are at
least based on real people
the first is the case of bernadette
subiru a 14 year old who grew up in
extreme famine in the mid-1800s in
france bernadette suffered from
intestinal problems and asthma since she
was little but after experiencing a
vision of a dazzling white figure as a
teen she was supposedly told to drink
this muddy spring water which that day
miraculously turned clear as the story
goes
the water was said to somehow be able to
cure the sick and people assumed the
spectral visitor to being the virgin
mary the second case was in 1917 in
portugal where three children named
lucia francisco and acenta reported
having encounters with apparitions of
the virgin mary just like the report in
france nearly 60 years before they
described a woman in white exuding a
sort of bright sunlight like rey the
woman promised the kids that if they
kept coming back she would perform a
miracle on october the 13th
which involved the sun coming out from
behind stormy clouds casting
multi-colored lights and appearing to
zoom forward and dry the clothes of the
onlookers standing in the rain
the third and final case was in 1981 in
bosnia where six kids saw a similar
woman
and now many visitors claim to also be
able to see her at certain times of day
the location draws thousands of pilgrims
every year each of these three locations
became holy
shrines and so the movie and the book
it's based on the shrine depict the
emergence of a fourth shrine in
massachusetts in the story each of the
three so-called miracles were followed
up by tragedy which was true in the case
of the three portuguese children who all
died in the next one to two years during
the 1918 flu pandemic ironically the
release of this movie would also be
hampered by a major pandemic to learn
some of the secrets of the dark fates
behind this event once heralded as a
modern day miracle
stick around to the end of this video
the unholy tells the story of this small
church town near boston being put on the
global map due to the supposed miracle
that takes place there when a deaf and
mute girl named alice is gifted with the
ability to hear and speak perfectly but
one journalist named jerry fenn begins
to suspect that the entity performing
these supposed miracles is anything but
a holy one
hence the title of the movie jerry was
once a prominent reporter but his desire
for fame pushed him to fabricate stories
leading to him being shunned by any
respectable publication we see he is now
working for a site called bizarre bean
town
beantown is a reference to the city of
boston once known for its baked beans
but jerry is sent to the countryside in
massachusetts to investigate his story
a small town by the name of banfield his
story turns out to be a dud
but when he happens across alice he
realizes he's got a much bigger scoop on
his hands before eventually discovering
that he may have put himself and many
others in grave grave danger
i've got a few things you'll want to
look out for when watching this movie so
let's get into them this video is
sponsored by sony pictures home
entertainment
[Music]
when jerry first arrives in banfield he
comes across this doll known as a kern
baby which is said to be planted there
by farmers as a token of good luck
however this particular one is labeled
with an impossible date
february 31st 1945 which is said to be
part of a practice to contain bad
spirits little did i know at the time
there are actually many stories of grave
markers and monuments with this date
while it can sometimes be used to denote
an unknown date many use it out of
superstition essentially the idea is
that the evil spirit will not be
released on any anniversary because the
date listed can never come
jerry shows his willingness to fudge a
story for money by breaking open the
kern baby
and making up a story about this
talisman being broken and an unholy evil
being released thirsty for blood
in this sense the story is kind of a
self-fulfilling prophecy and this is
where we start to see the signs that an
evil has indeed been unleashed but its
name is not virgin mary but rather
mary ellenor take the use of color for
example we all know from carrie's mom
that red is the color of the devil and
we see that reflected in alice who this
satanic entity speaks to and deceives
when we first lay eyes on her it's the
red tail lights of jerry's truck when
she gains her hearing back she undergoes
an auditory test which bathes her in red
light the water that mary elenor emerges
from in jerry's dream is
red and after she takes her first victim
this holy statue is illuminated in the
devil's color
these are all signs that what may appear
to be holy is actually a demonic trick
another example of this is the motel
that jerry stays in in banfield the sign
basks the entire area in red lights and
in more than one instance mary elenor
materializes from that direction
[Music]
you'll notice the sign is always
flickering and the letter m always
flicks independently of the other
letters could that possibly stand for
mary or
possibly miracle either way it draws my
attention and makes me think that
something isn't right here alice shows
that she's also able to help other
people get healed by mary when she helps
a crippled boy walk for the first time
and when she does something like this we
see one of these statues crying red
tears we see this happen a few times and
as a non-catholic i was curious about
what this may have signified so i looked
it up according to the site called the
conversation
mary cries not only over the sins of the
world but also over the pain she endured
in her earthly life
i think the meaning behind this imagery
in the movie is open to interpretation
these could be the real virgin mary's
tears and she's weeping for everyone who
is tricked into devoting themselves to a
false deity
or these could be mary ellenor's tears
for the pain that she endured in her
life which we see in the prologue i
think it's up to you to be on the
lookout and make the judgment as you
watch the film
another detail i found interesting was
alice's music preferences once she gains
the ability to hear she takes an
interest in country music but the song
we actually witness her listening to is
voices in my head by ashley tisdale
which must be connected to the way that
the false spirit communicates with her
where she's able to hear it but nobody
else is
one of the most interesting character
dynamics at play here is the
relationship between jerry and alice
jerry becomes the exclusive reporter who
has access to her and
in a strange way they both kind of
relate to each other alice is a girl who
is literally able to use her voice for
the first time and
jerry has in essence just gotten his
voice back or at least his journalistic
voice after being de-platformed by the
paper that he used to work for
this makes them both ideal victims for
mary elmore because they're both
desperate to speak freely
so despite this movie seeming to have a
bit of a message about just
being honest and humble in your work you
know there's still going to be some crew
reference easter eggs so here's a few of
them that you can look out for
during the news and social media montage
where word of alice's miracle is
spreading around the country there's an
instagram post from an account called
joshsg78 which was likely put there by
first assistant editor josh zigarlotta
later on there's a youtube live stream
of the ceremony at the new shrine on
sacramento tv
not to be confused with sakura tv from
death note there are only three people
active in the chat and they include
grace a reference to the vfx coordinator
and
nolan r the vfx editor i'm not sure who
ron bingo is but if anyone figures it
out drop me a comment
just taking a quick glance at some of
the ads for this movie i couldn't blame
you if you had the impression that it
was going to be somewhat similar to
2018's the nun
but outside of the generic concept of an
evil entity posing as a holy one it
really couldn't be much more different
instead of the expected haunted house
tropes the unholy is more of a character
piece with a dread that bubbles up
slowly until the big finale
[Applause]
you're not going to see bloody mary
popping up in the mirror for cheap
scares and it's kind of refreshing to
see a movie like this in a modern
setting with a touch of humor where
you have a son yeah
16 nice 15. you ever hear the band
metallica
i also mentioned the dream scene which
offers some surreal imagery that i liked
but what i was most impressed with was
the way that the film handles the
antagonist like the characters we kind
of slowly realize that mary ellenore is
not who she says she is but if you look
closely the clues are there
when alice first makes contact you can
see something that looks like a ghostly
figure fade before her which appears
again as a glitch in one of jerry's
videos
then when we actually do see the
creature who fittingly busts out of a
statue of the actual virgin mary
i won't spoil her appearance for those
who haven't seen it but it's like it's a
very own brand of creepy and i took a
liking to the way it looks the way it
moves and even the way it sounds it was
all very unique in a modern horror
landscape that already has
a lot of demon characters if you haven't
seen the movie yet
you are in luck you can get it now on
digital or on blu-ray
and if you love horror you're already
right where you need to be just go ahead
and subscribe to cz's world for new
horrors every week
ring the death bell for all
notifications and i'll see you in the
next one
assuming we both survive and if you
haven't already
vaccinate and annihilate